at any point when you were making this
did you think of having somebody else
direct this and then did you have to
grab it back and think no I have to do
this I as I was writing it I had I
wasn't really thinking I wasn't I wasn't
thinking about that I had a very clear
vision of what I was wanting it to be
I'm chiefly that it would be a very warm
film and very generous and but I because
what I envisioned was so clear by that
when I was finished with it I was
frightened but I felt that um I just
wanted to do it because I so clearly had
these feelings that I wanted to make
sure it were translated in the piece and
that it wasn't going to be a that it
would be humorous and that it would be
not really not not so sad I felt like
someone else might take it make it
really really sad because there were so
many sad elements in it but I sort of
thought I want to do a celebration of
misery well there's a title for you and
about the title so many people have
commented on it a critic I spoke to who
loved it said if there were one thing
she could change it would be the title
where does it come from because I don't
recall hearing the line but it had to
have come from one of you kids well
where it came from actually was my
father which was when I was in college
my father I went my sister and I were at
Harvard my father was lived in Cambridge
and he was having a manic episode and we
felt that he should go to the hospital
before it got out of control we took him
to McLean Hospital in belmont and he was
filling out his intake form and it said
have you ever been diagnosed with a
mental illness if so what would you know
manic depression bipolar schizophrenic
schizophrenia other he circled other and
wrote instantly polar bear and what
struck me was that it's so hard to go
through life with labels that that tell
you that there's something wrong with
you and as much as my father was open
about being manic depressive which was
his the Labour label he favored over
bipolar it's still hard to to be
burdened with that through life and so
it was
sort of it was a way of giving himself a
label for his condition that wasn't that
didn't have sort of all these negatives
of clinical yeah clinical that wasn't
being told to him by somebody else this
is what you have and we sort of this is
a lot that I have instantly polar bear
that's what I have you you have great
comedy writing chops and credentials and
I'm wondering how that influenced us
because a lot of the time I know friends
whose parents were horrible and they
would be thinking I wish my dad were
like that that looks like fun well the
what's funny to me is the clash between
the father and the daughters and also
what's funny is that they don't when
he's running you know when they're
running down the hall to get to school
they're all screaming down the hall and
you know he's yelling for his daughter
and and we were just so oblivious to the
fact that people don't really like it
when you're yelling screaming down the
hall I mean there was so many funny when
I was looking back at it so many funny
you know when when he gets the dog you
know the girls love the dog but from for
Maggie you know the fact that he's
brought now a crazy dog into the mix is
really not not it was not a solution for
the what's going on in their marriage or
anything so there was it was the
perspective on all of those things where
the comedy comes from I mean certainly I
feel that I got tremendous amount of
gifts front from my father but it was
also very hard and one of the gifts that
I got was how hard it was to care for
somebody who has all these wonderful
qualities but can't pull his life
together you know when I felt like I we
always wanted to fix him I would you
couldn't fix him and so that there's a
lot of pain and lessons in that but um I
guess in looking back at the movie I
felt that it had made me a some more
self-reliant person a person capable of
loving other people and I learned a lot
you lived this in the first person but
you made the film in the third person
how different was that what did you
change and how aware were you of things
that you had to change to make this into
a film well it's not you know it would
be different if I were writing a memoir
but obviously
film is so collaborative and and you're
you're going to bring actors into it and
I sort of what happened for me was that
I would I was trying to figure out a way
into the story how wide is this why is
this man left these two daughters and
with his daughters and how do I explain
this and it was hard because that's it's
a really great crazy situation and I
thought should I these are wait should I
be getting rid of the mother somehow or
you know to just to make it easy
palatable for people to understand but
then that felt wrong because it was such
an interesting part of the story I felt
just in terms of what it had to say
about women and motherhood gender roles
ambition that time feminism race because
my mother is black but I don't look
black and I just decided I was going to
go for it on the big all the big things
you know the that's the situation with
my parents marriage or and my father's
manic depression the fact that he's from
this old money family all these sort of
big details I thought I'm going to be
true to those then within within it the
story is some memory but it's also
stories that were told to me by other
people by other people things other
people it's a distillation I was really
going for something that felt true but
to get to that truth lots of things had
to be stripped away and I had to be
simplified and also to get to the to the
tone of the piece which was I wanted to
be funny and sad you know that was also
a big balancing act what had to be
stripped away and how much of that was a
result of the collaboration that you
talk of that's intrinsic to film Wow it
had to be stripped I mean so uh the time
period had to be condensed so you know
in reality probably this whole thing
stretched over you would have to recast
these girls a number of times I didn't
want to have to do that Russia since one
was your daughter and she might not have
been pleased yes he would do it very
but I so I had so what had to be I mean
also just I couldn't go to New York we
couldn't go to New you know I couldn't
go shoot anything in New York so I
couldn't have south station in Boston
where we spent a lot of time picking my
mother up there were just a lot of
things that sort of just because we're
making a film in 2013 is when we shot it
and trying to evoke the period there's
no Harvard Square I'm at our home away
from home harvard square isn't really
there anymore the way it was and we
couldn't suit there anyway so i just i
mean they're a lot i just had fewer
carrot you know that's it's a I had to
simplify it to its essence I guess I was
trying to get to something essential did
making this film change your perception
of your childhood at all I it well it
ain't my perception of myself it did
change my perception of my childhood
because I I was so I started writing it
because my kids are growing up in this
time where I feel like everything is
terrifying you know it's like they can't
walk outside they can't do it I feel
like they're gonna any choice you make
their doomed so I was reflecting on my
own child into thinking wait I think I
got a lot out of all these kind of tough
things that I went through and maybe I
don't need to worry about my kids
surviving or anything maybe I just have
to say you'll figure it out you'll be
okay you know whatever comes your way it
may be hard I mean a lot of the issues
in this film I wrestled with for years
but I and I'm still a work in progress
and I'm still wrestling with things but
but I did feel like I learned how to do
that that's very critical I learned how
to be interested in people and I a lot
of compassion my father both my parents
are very compassionate and they had a
good sense of humor and these are all
the little things that i got and um so I
yes I guess it did I felt like I guess
I'm lucky to have that child